you said to my face that you never
turned into the Abomination anymore no I
said I choose not to you know these were
extenuating circumstances
understand that this constitutes another
crime and totally destroys your chances
at parole well
no because I was forced
to leave my cell but I returned
of my own free will who forced you to
escape this insanely high security
prison undetected a sorcerer Supreme of
the Mystic Arts and his name is
long just Wong and his internet presence
is a little chaotic he's either a
sorcerer who lives in New York or a
librarian who lives in Nepal can you get
to him yes Jen it's me of course I can
get to him I sent a thirst trap
it was a picture of me with a bunch of
books I just hope that he calls back you
know if blonsky's telling the truth this
guy busted him out of his prison cell
and probably ruined my entire case
what happened to me
[Music]
I'm sorry I tried to warn you my blood
got into your system so I didn't turn
into a Hulk now too
how are you
[Music]
Miss Walters we just started a
superhuman law Division and I want the
She-Hulk to be the invasive I can't wait
to take on whatever case you want to
assign here the first case is the parole
of Emile Blonsky also known as
Abomination Jennifer Wars I've already
got a winning strategy and it is a
hundred percent in the bag uh you might
want to take a look at the news right
after shocking footage leaked showing
the Abomination participating in what
appears to be an underground Fight Club
after having escaped from prison